[Music]
so there's a volunteer group of moms in
mexico
and they go out and try to find missing
loved ones it's pretty cute
what are you gonna fight the cartel
it sounds like a terrible idea oh i
thought it was going to be like but then
i met this girl it's kind of cute yeah i
thought it was going to be like i met
this girl in tulum and we're so drunk
and we [ __ ] loved miss connections
yeah that was a misconception craigslist
yeah that's kind of dope and then
they're like mom's to the rescue all
right we got this one matchmaking
matchmaking mexican moms triple m we
should just start reading like
connections
four
four m that'd be dope i wish
that's a [ __ ] sci-fi shoe yeah she
was assigned my shirt yeah i saw a hot
girl in a white bikini mama find her
i wish there's like the hacker version
they all have a uh m for last name too
like morales is a hacker mom yeah
there's a hacker mom she goes she's like
the one that's like at home with the
baby and [ __ ] buddy i found this girl on
instagram she looks like the one in the
description but her facebook says she
lives over here
well i wish it ended with that much
happiness but oh
god dude
all the sad stuff today with the cartel
stuff so
yeah you did i know volunteer group of
moms in mexico went out searching for
missing loved ones
and ended up
discovering 17 other bodies buried in
abandoned residential yards god damn all
in one place
in very
close proximity that's some cartoons
coincidence 17. it's absolutely cartel
[ __ ] yeah so like i guess in that area
that they were looking the cartel kind
of they'll go to like these abandoned
houses in these residential areas and
they'll do the killings there and then
just bury them in those yards
and then um these moms just happened to
find those exact places they just
started digging and they just uncovered
seventeen bodies yeah but they weren't
surprised this evening gets out because
then like who do they tell because
aren't the cops like under the cartel
like everybody's like stacked i mean i
don't know maybe these moms are off
limits yeah kind of like you know
abuelas and stuff
i don't know there's there's full
villages and cities that um fight back
too
yeah there's zones where
the cartel just you know and it's really
sad because the reason they formed this
group is because the cops refused to
search in the places that they wanted to
look for sure for that reason yeah well
the cops don't want to die they want
their whole family to get kidnapped and
[ __ ] it seems like such a different
planet yeah you know like america's got
its issues right we got a problem but
that is an entirely different issue so
like this is just my impression i don't
know if this is accurate but like is
mexico that incompetent as far as law
enforcement i think they're it's pretty
bad i don't know
is the wrong word yeah i don't think
it's incompetent uh i i think i think
under the thumb of yeah yeah
they have zero chances it's like
it's a multiple symptom thing one it's
like
uh the there's a huge like uh
discrepancy and like the rich and the
poor right so there's already people
that are extremely economically
disadvantaged so when you have that then
people are just desperate
and then if you have something that's
extremely highly lucrative and then you
have people that have extreme violence
because like the people that are part of
the cartel they're like former mexico
their version of navy seals they can pay
off the they can pay off um what is it
called the cops easy they have extreme
amounts of threat in them yeah yeah they
they have all the resources they have
literally like submarines and tanks and
[ __ ] that they buy from like old like uh
uh decommissioned like russian um
military assets so it's just a [ __ ]
like crazy all-around ecosystem
i don't think this shit's new though
right like way back in the day it's
religion religion had their thumb on on
on countries and control yeah and then
like even like joking but not like mafia
similar thing like hey man
you run this store you want that glass
to be broken tomorrow or do you want to
protect it okay give me 10 percent and
then like
racketeering yeah and then it just
starts to build up one store after
another city after city cop after coffee
even like in the 60s right like in new
york like how many of the cops were
under the italian mobs yeah influence
yeah it just takes time you know we
don't have to throw it italian we don't
have this big nose people get it you
don't have to say it
that's kind of cool though right because
it's [ __ ] rad and we did it with
straight respect all right we had morals
because there's footage of mexican like
police and armies getting into uh
firefights with the cartel so not all of
them are paid off and not all of them
are working for the cartel but it also
might be it's not one cartel there's
multiple different regions and there's
there's mayors still there's governors
there are different puzzles involved
so i i think um it's a complex issue but
the funny thing is that
some of these cartel guys were trained
by the us military because they were the
special like let's say dea swat guys of
mexico they got trained by our special
forces and then they go you know what
all these
drug guys are making a ton
why don't we just take over their
business and then that's what they did
and then some dude these businesses they
make so much [ __ ] money like they
probably make more than the government
and they've had like assassinations like
out in the public like you'll be like uh
like let's say a mayor or a a cardinal
even that condemned the cartel and then
boom the next day you see that car roll
up and then [ __ ] bullet holes go
straight through the [ __ ] the car
like the next mayor they're like oh [ __ ]
am i going to say anything about the
cartel or do i want to get [ __ ]
assassinated and brown david
that's why i was always wondering like
if um
the news that does reach stateside they
just really love to tell us how [ __ ]
up it is yeah but if it's one of those
places where if you go there and you
kind of know the deal and know the rules
you'll be fine yeah i think there's that
too yeah i i i went to uh cancun tulum
um playa del carmen
all the touristy places right and what
shocked me or what made it real is like
okay you think you're just in the
country and it's like oh cool you know
and then when you see four or five
truckloads that's so scary of dudes in
military uniform and straight looking
like they're about to go into war
and driving past you that's when you're
just like oh [ __ ] hey guys
can you take my photo
what i also heard too is along the
united states bottom border is where
their heaviest presence is because
they're trying to smuggle it in but when
you go into like deep mexico then it's
like any other country that you go into
okay like if you go to like mexico city
it feels like a mexico like downtown l.a
where it's not
there's not like a [ __ ] tank rolling
through with people throwing gang signs
and stuff you know yeah so just as a
tank
that's pretty tight
walking on the floor
this has an added stat currently the
mexican government data shows 98 356
reported missing people
what's america's reported missing people
though i don't know i think it's higher
i think not well higher because we have
more people too but i think it's way
high compared to what even our news
stations tell people really i think so i
think i think we're missing cats left
and right bro in the us it's
oh
more than 17 000 missing person cases
remain open
california has 2133 they did this um so
it's not that crazy they were
extraditing uh a mexican cartel dude
right they caught this boss
uh he was like a leader big time guy and
then they were transporting the convoy
back into the states and then the convoy
got attacked and then
it's [ __ ] the fire power that the
cartel has it's like
it's like isis you know like yeah just
straight rocketing blowing up trying to
[ __ ] get to this stage right and i
was like that's crazy dude like that's
like some fast and furious [ __ ]
but that happens
yeah fast and furious is pretty high
level [ __ ] they'll be like stopping
planes and stuff with cars a drama
documentary yeah yeah definitely like
halfway but i'm wondering like how much
jesus is in it how much of that happens
here
and it's not reported on the news yeah i
do wonder i'd be shocked if that kind of
[ __ ] happens in the states
where like let's say a big time
billionaire criminal is like being
convoyed somewhere and then like it gets
attacked by i don't know dudes that want
to get them back or is it like
really hard to do that on american soil
i don't know
i don't know either yeah yeah
cartel stuff scares the [ __ ] at me i
didn't know like uh one of my cop
friends did tell me like they were able
to bust down this door
and they found out some cartel operation
and then the two dudes they arrested
um they were put on a million dollar
bail each so for them they're like okay
cool these fools aren't going anywhere
for sure they got posted bail
immediately and then within like two
hours they already left yeah i would be
scared that's the kind of resources they
have dude they're like
what are we even fighting this for this
is above our pay grade this is some
crazy [ __ ] they're like maybe we should
have done 2 million
my one of my clients
his uh
one of his really good friends
got shot in like a gang shooting right
he was in the hospital they found out
that he was undocumented
why like while he was in the hospital he
was like arrested um they patched him up
and then they sent them over back to
mexico
he gets picked up by the cartel
and then he just starts trimming weed
plans for him
for like a couple weeks
and then
they're like hey they give them the
phone they say hey call your parents or
whatever they call their parents and
then they're just asking for like four
hundred dollars like or i forgot what
the exact amount was like not even that
much yeah but like they were asking for
um like a monthly payment just to keep
him alive
and then that was the last extortion
and like that's what he told and i was
like that's [ __ ] yeah in sync yeah
and they didn't get him back or nothing
well you know he he said he hasn't
talked to him since [ __ ]
but this was also like five years ago
yeah wow so you've been trimming wheeze
for like five years i have no idea maybe
because they're like sorry because of
covid we can't send them
in mexico it says there's 52 000 dead
bodies that have not been identified yet
52 yet so they're still they're like
working on it
oh but tulum is so lit though you got to
go there dude it is so awesome well not
okay
it is beautiful but then like what's
really cool is the chitsa and like
and then like that's the pyramids that
the mayans made and then if you stand
there you go like like that and you clap
and it goes
every time you clap and you're like this
is [ __ ] ancient alien [ __ ] man
it's so cool it's pretty magical right
here we have cenotes where you could
swim in the water and [ __ ] it's so
selling it man i like it all right i'm
going to tulum dude
to me it was safe it was nice i highly
recommend it thirsty spots are cool and
then i these are they said it's owned by
the cartel that's what people say so
they're like
no no yeah we're going to keep our
business going i don't think they want
to [ __ ] with america you know they want
to keep their [ __ ] going if they kill an
american it's not going to look good no
they'll kidnap americans i'm sure they
do here and there but you know what i
mean like that's going to make way more
news than
52 000 mexican locals disappeared right
no one's gonna come over but yeah i did
i did watch a really cool um anonymous
interview from like this mexican cartel
hitman and he said one of the rules is
that they just don't kill journalists
that makes sense because they don't like
tattletails well because they said if
you kill it he said if you you can kill
anybody he's like if you can kill cop
but he said if you kill a journalist
there's so much empathy from the world
about what you did that people will
never stop coming to find out what
happened like the guy who killed the
journalists in the submarine do you guys
hear about that stuff no i didn't
i'm gonna i'm gonna wear a journalist
tag when i go to mexico just always have
a [ __ ] clipboard
and i'm gonna have a [ __ ]
international like war thing
ukraine everyone's wearing press to make
sure i'm like
you think they're aiming down that
sniper and just not going to pick you
they're not supposed to
[Music]